[Music]
hey guys it's Justine and today is an
extremely exciting video I know I say
that a lot of the isn't it exciting but
this one is even more exciting because
today I am going to Jonathan studio and
your surprising a lil darielle
some of you may know of her because he's
made videos about her in the past but
I'm gonna put a link in the description
if you want to check it out it's a link
to her GoFundMe page you can find out
more about her and her story so we're
gonna head in here very shortly so she
doesn't know that I'm gonna be here so
Jonathan set this little thing up he has
one of her favorite bands performing and
we're also surprising her with an iPhone
and an Apple watch this is going to be
incredible we also brought Maddie to
baby we're gonna surprise
Aereo Vincent my job to Jenna's here the
surprise and Tyler's here too
you can do this
[Music]
over here yes this is so exciting I mean
you've been planning this for a while
it's been like over a year how long have
you known Ariel so she's been a
supporter like the technology forever
but I've got a chance like know her know
her over the past year and a half and
she's even cooler this is incredible so
walk me through what's gonna happen
right now
so Arielle was chilling I'm gonna go get
her I'm gonna take her and let her know
that we're hanging with Terry jr. which
is one of her favorite groups she can
hang out watch them record an acoustic
performance and then by the end of that
you'll start walking in and bust in like
Santa Justine this is gonna be great
we're getting her and her sister iPhones
and Apple watches like this is gonna be
awesome
but thanks for making this all happen
and I'm so excited to see everything
right Oh Cal me to hell with it probably
like seven so check your phone okay so
now we wait she's gonna text me when
it's time and there we go Jonathan said
come over in six minutes it has been
like four minutes we're gonna get a head
start just to get there in case I get
lost
came out of here Eddie Jenna's gonna
take you I'm gonna grab the bag of
goodies this is where the real surprise
is oh my gosh I hope she's enjoying her
first surprise
I guess with the way I'm so nervous
I can hear them performing
the now just announced it now
hello oh sorry
I've post mates did you guys order some
stuff is this the right place this post
mates here hi I'm Justine I'm your post
mate how are you maddie is also here our
dog how are you it's so nice to finally
meet you
oh this is amazing
we've got some phones here's a new
iPhone from Jonathan and I hold on here
we have something else too and an Apple
watch and then are you our sister I'm
Justine hi I also have something for you
as well nice to meet you
we'll have a phone for you and an Apple
watch so now you guys can match thank
you oh this is so great yes thank you
how are you did I miss the performance
no no we're getting on to actually kind
of a cool classic oh nice I really want
to impress so to be honest he's actually
a DJ so his Instagram is DJ mini Matt
and he has his own little DJ set and he
DJ's
so museums
[Laughter]
[Music]
we copy say you got something
got a strike
need you
me
three
[Music]
so good thanks for sharing your presence
yes thank you for making this all happen
for coordinating yeah you're stressed
aren't you it was okay so we had the
surprise and I walked up and I stacked
like Elsa postmates did you guys
actually think I was close made
literally thought you were like just
breaking in oh then you saw Maddie
Maddie ran up there to be a part of the
show that's awesome well so nice to meet
you
well thank you guys so much make sure
you go check out all the links below
that I would put in the description and
I will see you later and Jonathan thank
you so much for coordinating all this he
could tell he was super stressed he's
like coordinating everything like trying
to make sure we're all here and it
worked so thank you
it's so great
[Music]